- It's time to play,
You Give Us 6 Seconds,
We'll Give You The World.
(applause)
And to help us introduce
this next game,
please welcome our
Vinetern contest winner
and official at Midnight
Vinetern, Mike Bennett.
(applause)
Hey.
- Hey.
- Sorry Mike you're an intern,
I don't share the podium.
- Completely understand.
- How you doin' man?
- I'm doing well, how about you?
- Can't look you in the
eye, you're an intern.
- I understand.
(laughter)
- Gotta keep you down.
- It's tough to be a
TV reporter these days.
- Tell me about it sister.
- Yeah, you have to keep up
with the 24 hour news cycle
and you have to appear on air
knowing that if you mess up
your humiliation will
be looped on Vine
for all of eternity.
So here's what I thought
that would look like.
- [Host] Alright.
- Now over to Mike
who's on the scene.
Thanks Rob.
(laughter)
- Not bad intern, not bad.
(applause)
Why don't we--
What are you getting to do this?
College credit or something?
- T-Shirt.
(laughter)
- Alright, thanks so much Mike.
You can see Mike's work on
the @Midnight Vine account,
give it up for us,
@Midnight Vinetern.
Get outta here!
So adorable.
He's learning how to grow facial
hair and button his shirt.
You know, they gotta
leave the nest some day.
Alright comedians, I'm
gonna show you a Vine
hashtag news fail and for
250 points you give me
a headline describing it.
First up, let's look at
this sidewalk sneak up.
(speaking foreign language)
(laughter)
- I'm real nervous
about where you guys
are gonna go with this one.
Neal Brennan.
- I'm a promoter bro, come
to my club, come to my club,
come to my club.
(applause)
- [Host] Ali.
- Man gets shot for
interrupting white people.
(laughter)
(applause)
- [Host] Tom.
- Sacha Baron Cohen
promoting new movie.
- Yes, perfect, yeah
good, alright nice.
You guys did very well.
Next one, get help girl there's
trouble at the old farm.
- 500 birds, they're
being judged today
at the show.
(screaming)
(laughing)
(ding)
- Neal.
- Cock attacks Jim for a change.
(laughter)
- Points, Tom.
- Black cock
frightens white man.
- Yes, points.
(laughter)
(applause)
Ali.
- Local coward acts
like a little bitch.
(laughter)
(applause)
- Alright then there's
this forgetful anchor.
- Good evening, I'm Oprah.
(laughter)
(ding)
- [Host] Tom.
- Set designer still
feels 47 not big enough.
- Points, I like,
points yes well done.
Neal.
- Stedman gets first
boner in years.
(laughter)
(applause)
He'll probably forgive me.
- [Host] Ali.
- News anchor says what
every woman is thinking.
- Points, points.
You're getting points,
and you're getting points,
and you're getting points!
(applause)
Hey, hey, hey you guys aren't
getting fuckin' points.
(laughter)
Next one, this
reporter on assignment.
- ABC7, would you
not eat my pants?
(screaming)
(laughter)
- Well technically he
did what she asked,
he didn't eat her pants.
Neal Brennan.
- Jean died doing what she
loved, being attacked by goats.
- Yeah, points, okay good.
Last one, this beat reporter.
- Either way in the
next hour or so--
(laughter)
(ding)
- Yeah I love to drop
a good ol' sodomy bomb
in the back of a video.
Neal.
- Comcast customer
service hits new low.
(laughter)
(applause)
- [Host] Tom.
- News report from inside
rest area men's room
goes exactly as planned.
(laughter)
- [Host] Ali.
- Ordinary day in San Francisco.
(laughter)
- Yeah you know, points.
(applause)